ja ich berichte seit drei Jahren über
die Pandemie begleite die Impfstoffe
seit von Beginn an und ich hätte ehrlich
gesagt nicht gedacht dass mich noch
etwas überraschen kann bei den
Impfstoffen das hat es aber dann doch
ich konnte nämlich viele Dokumente
einsehen Protokolle zu Forschung mit
vielen
Kandidaten sprechen die diese Impfstoffe
getestet haben auch Studienleiter und so
weiter und all das hat sich
zusammengesetzt zu einem Bild das nun
ergibt dass während der Zulassungsstudie
doch viele ungeranntheiten auftauchen
das geht los damit dass schwere im
Nebenwirkungen die tatsächlich
aufgetreten sind offenbar verheimlicht
wurden auch vertuscht wurden das
Todesfälle möglicherweise auch nicht
dort in der Studie aufgetaucht sind wo
sie eigentlich hätten stehen sollen
ich habe mit einem Impfstoffkandidaten
gesprochen der in Buenos Aires den
Impfstoff getestet hat der wurde der
hatte schwere Nebenwirkungen und wurde
zu einem covid-opfer um umgefällt
dieser Fall ist besonders
[Musik]
gravierend weil er eben der Kandidat
heißt augusteuruk ist ein argentinia und
sein Fall taucht auch nicht in der
Zulassungsstudie auf
er hatte eine Perikarditis und
das ist eine der schweren Nebenwirkungen
die gleich nach Beginn der Zulassung der
Impfstoffe aufgetreten sind hätte man
ihn oder möglicherweise auch andere
Fälle die möglicherweise eben auch
vertuscht wurden hätte man diese Fälle
in die Zulassungsstudie einfließen
lassen dann wäre sehr viel früher klar
geworden dass möglicherweise junge
Menschen
schwere Nebenwirkungen erleiden können
durch den Impfstoff diese ganzen Fälle
werfen Fragen auf
zum einen schauen die Behörden wirklich
ernsthaft genug hin bei der wenn Sie
diese Impfstoffe zulassen und zum
anderen auch
begleitet man die industrielle Forschung
kritisch genug schaut man wirklich gut
hin wenn
Medikamente wenn Impfstoffe
wenn neue
gesundheitsrelevante Produkte auf den
Markt kommen müsste man da nicht besser
genug hinschauen
mit all dem was sie recherchiert haben
und sie haben jetzt auch ein Beispiel in
ihren Recherchen genannt kommen Sie dazu
dem Fazit dass man den Impfstoff so zu
diesem Zeitpunkt gar nicht hätte
zulassen dürfen
doch ich denke man muss vor Augen haben
dass es damals es ist ja jetzt schon
mehr als zwei Jahre her man muss vor
Augen haben dass es damals sehr das
ganze Thema Corona sehr brisant war es
war auch es ging um Tempo ich weiß dass
wir in der Redaktion darüber gesprochen
haben wann bekommen wir in Deutschland
endlich den Impfstoff wann lass dir den
endlich zu in der Europäischen Union wir
haben wir haben auf die immer geschaut
wir haben gesagt ist die immer jetzt
wirklich so langsam guckt mal in den USA
sind die so viel schneller da war Trump
damit Rock Speed wir haben die
Amerikaner alle ein bisschen beneidet
haben gesagt die lassen sich jetzt schon
impfen wo bleibt der Impfstoff für uns
von daher haben wir Journalisten
natürlich auch aufs Tempo gedrückt und
ähm die Zeit war knapp der Winter kam
und wir haben alle auf den Impfstoff
gehofft dann dachte das sei die große
Rettung das würde quasi die Pandemie
beenden so wurde es ja auch gesagt von
der Politik genau sagen sie glauben sie
mit dem Kenntnisstand und auch mit oder
ihren Recherchen heute hätte man
vielleicht dann nur die wunderbaren
Gruppen impfen sollen
vielleicht das denke ich auf jeden Fall
und das habe ich auch von Anfang an
eigentlich immer gesagt
wir erinnern uns die wunderbaren Gruppen
also die alten standen natürlich an
erster Stelle
es war aber es lief so ein bisschen
durcheinander auch in Deutschland und es
ging dann auch sehr schnell darum
die jungen Leute zu impfen und auch
Kinder und auch Kinder das das wurde
dann sehr stark gefordert es wurde auch
dann auch von der Ständigen
Impfkommission so empfohlen ähm ich sehe
das ich sehe das etwas kritisch ich
denke auch mit dem Wissen von heute wenn
man jetzt auf die Zulassungsstudien
zurückzieht wenn man
immer wieder tauchen auch neue Studien
auf die zeigen dass es für für Kinder
eben doch nicht so ganz ohne ist da
sollte man das doch sehr neu Platten da
sollte auch die Ständige Impfkommission
sich dazu äußern und sagen
für Kinder sollte man diesen Impfstoff
möglicherweise hinten anstellen aber die
STIKO wurde ja nach ihren Worten quasi
auch getäuscht wenn falsche
Informationen von den Studien
weitergegeben werden verschleiert werden
und Informationen unter den Tisch fallen
dann ist quasi niemand in der Lage eine
Bewertung abzugeben ja also ich denke
dass die Behörden damals also natürlich
allen voran die FDA die hat als erstes
zugelassen die haben die amerikanische
Gesundheitsbehörde aber auch die
europäische Gesundheitsbehörde immer die
haben natürlich aufs Tempo gedrückt die
haben das wissen wir heute die haben
sich auch bevor Sie die Unterlagen
überhaupt einsehen konnten hatten die
sich schon auf einen zulassungstermin
geeinigt das heißt es war eigentlich
klar das Ding muss jetzt kommen so war
natürlich auch die Stimmung und wir
haben das damals glaube ich alle so
gesehen dass das war ja auch in Ordnung
so
trotzdem hätte man sich gewünscht dass
an der einen oder anderen Stelle genauer
hingesehen worden wäre und gerade dann
mit diesem wissen heute
dass also es gab danach noch einmal eine
Zulassung das war Anfang 2000 das war
Mitte 2022 Entschuldigung und da wurden
eigentlich die Fehler wiederholt meiner
Meinung nach die Ende 2020 schon einmal
gemacht wurde da da wurde da hieß es
auch wir müssen das jetzt schnell
zulassen das waren die Omegon
angepassten Impfstoffe
da hätte man meiner Meinung nach also
spätestens dann hätte man meine Meinung
nach dann doch etwas mehr Zeit sich
lassen können und die Daten sich genauer
hätte ansehen können dann gab es ja noch
einen anderen der Impfstoff für Weg der
hieß es immer der kommt bald der kommt
bald dann kann man plötzlich gar nicht
glauben sie dass da quasi ich sag mal so
sauberer gearbeitet wurde sauberer
geforscht wurde der deswegen nicht auf
den Markt kam oder wie erklären Sie sich
das das kann ich nicht einschätzen
meines Wissens auch im Ausland Studien
gemacht die Unterlagen wurden meines
Wissens nicht veröffentlicht
letztlich ist curvec dann daran
gescheitert dass die Effizienz nicht gut
genug war also man muss als Hersteller
muss man eine bestimmte eine bestimmte
Grenzwert überschreiten an Wirksamkeit
muss man nachweisen und dass das nicht
gelungen und das ist zum einen tragisch
weil auch in Deutschland sehr viel Geld
in diesen Impfstoff gesteckt wurde
andererseits natürlich
das eigentlich auch ein schöner
deutscher Erfolg gewesen wäre wenn neben
biontech auch noch ein weiterer
Hersteller damit auf dem Markt gekommen
wäre
das ist nun nicht gelungen über die
Gründe kann man sich jetzt auch nicht
sagen glauben Sie denn jetzt sehen wir
ja das immer mehr im Schäden auch
sozusagen ans Tageslicht kommen das ist
wahnsinnig schwer nachzuweisen aber wir
sehen wir hatten Menschen die einen im
schaden sich bei sich vermuten hier in
der Sendung die dramatisch Leiden das
sind auch auch Themen die gehen jetzt
alle Medien an auch große Reportagen bei
den Öffentlich-Rechtlichen glauben Sie
anhand ihrer Recherchen werden wir viel
mehr über diese Impfschäden reden müssen
und auch da viel mehr Transparenz
schaffen müssen glauben sie dass da auch
eine Zahl auf uns zukommt mit der wir
jetzt noch gar nicht so richtig rechnen
das kann ich schwer einschätzen ich
denke dass
das sehen wir ja schon heute sind schon
heute sehr viel mehr Menschen
die jetzt auch vor Gericht gehen die
Entschädigung fordern als ursprünglich
damit gerechnet wurde in der
Zulassungsstudie war es ja so der hieß
es gibt eigentlich keine schweren
Nebenwirkungen das Zeug ist sicher
was ich jetzt gesehen habe der eine Fall
aus Argentinien mit seiner schweren Herz
Herzmuskelentzündung aber auch andere
Fälle die damals während der
Zulassungsstudie einfach ausgeschlossen
wurde es gibt auch eine Amerikanerin
Medi the Garry heißt die das ist ein
junges Mädchen das was heute im
Rollstuhl sitzt auch das wurde in der
zulass in der Zulassungsstudien nicht
erwähnt also sie sie wurde sie viel dort
nicht sie wurde dort nicht mit dem
Impfstoff in Zusammenhang gebracht
wenn man das alles
berücksichtigt hätte dann hätte man
gewusst dass junge Menschen
tatsächlich ein höheres Risiko haben für
Nebenwirkungen als als eben
ältere Menschen
dann hätte man vermutlich auch
eher gezögert mit diesen starken
Empfehlungen für die Impfstoffe sie da
auch wirklich impfen zu lassen
da muss man finde ich schon ein
Fragezeichen dahinter setzen wieder die
Kommunikation gelaufen ist das klingt
Herr Kreis alles wirklich brutal wir
sind würde ich sagen erst in den
anfangen diese Aufarbeitung der
coronazeit wenn sie jetzt ihre
Recherchen von Frau Buderus hören was
geht ihnen dadurch den Kopf wie blicken
sie auf die corona-krise und auch die
Impfkampagne die auch weiterhin läuft es
geht weiter beispielsweise Impfpflicht
in der Bundeswehr die nicht ausgesetzt
wird also was kann man da jetzt langsam
machen wenn sie so etwas hören das geht
ihn durch den Kopf
möchte ja da war ist eine Stimmung da
gewesen das war kein Zufall diese
Stimmung ist systematisch erzeugt worden
durch die impflobby durch die
Pharma-Lobby ist es im am 16 März 2020
ist eine Studie erschienen vom Imperial
College von Neil Ferguson des Imperial
College ist durchsetzt von der
pharma-lobbys tritt trotzdem als
Universität auf Nil Fergus und sein
Professor der ist massiv gesponsert
durch die infloppy diese Studie vom 16
März 20 ganz ganz früh gesagt wir werden
ein Millionen her von Toten sehen es
werden sich sieben Milliarden Menschen
infizieren die infloppy hat ja massiv
über Fake seiens über gekaufte
Wissenschaft ein Panik aufgebaut die
gestreut und dadurch ist diese Stimmung
erzeugt und diese Panik erzeugt worden
diese Angst gemacht worden das war kein
Zufall und dann waren wir plötzlich
gesagt wir brauchen es wirklich beiden
Impfstoff das sind der war ganz viel
manipulierte Daten es war ein reines
Modell von dem Nil Ferguson der schon in
der Vergangenheit permanent sich geirrt
hat Dezember zugunsten der im Flori und
zwar Faktor 10.000 100.000 hatte immer
mehr Tote vorhergesagt als dann
tatsächlich kamen übrigens Herr Drosten
auch war mit seinen Prognosen damals zur
Schweinegrippe was glaube ich dramatisch
falsch ein genialer fehlprognostiker und
diese Menschen die sich immer zugunsten
der impflobby der Pharma Lobby
dramatisch irren die werden dann zu dem
Protagonisten der Politik erklärt die
machen dann unsere impfpolitik dass es
im massiven Umfang
naja problematische Wissenschaft und das
hat System diese Angst aufzubauen diese
Angst zu schüren da konnten sich dann
als Politiker schwer entziehen die
Medien konnten sich dem schweren ziehen
in die Studien waren ständig in im
Vordergrund diese Studie von Professor
Dr und wir später genannt wird
vorgesehen hat fast die gesamte
angesächsische Welt in Lockdown
geschickt und im Nachhinein stellt fest
das waren ja alles zahlen die absolut
nicht haltbar waren also im Nachhinein
genau diese wieder Fake Seins wieder
gekaufte Wissenschaften massiv gewirkt
hat da sind wir schon fast drin in ihrem
Thema da gehen wir nämlich gleich im
Anschluss auch noch mal ganz tief reine
Herr Bolz die Beispiele die Frau boderas
da gerade genannt hat das sind schon
massive Beispiele massive Fälle die da
einfach unter den Tisch fallen die nicht
auftauchen in einer Studie die dann zu
einer Bewertung einer Zulassung dienen
soll das geht ihnen dadurch den Kopf ja
ich bin ehrlich gesagt nicht so sehr
überrascht das ist so läuft weil eben
wirtschaftliche Interessen politische
Interessen der doch immer eine
Hauptrolle spielen und das was sie uns
wahrscheinlich auch gleich präsentieren
werden das ist etwas was ich seit langer
langer Zeit mit größter Sorge betrachte
ich nenne diese Leute
gefälligkeitswissenschaftler also
Wissenschaftler die genau die Ergebnisse
liefern die die Politik braucht oder die
besondere gewisse Wirtschaftsinteressen
stützen und das ist eine traurige
Entwicklung also dass diese alte
Orientierung die klassische Orientierung
der Wissenschaft zumindest Sicherheit
anzustreben wenn sie auch nicht so
erreichen ist dass die zunehmend ersetzt
wird durch
interessenorientierte Studien denn man
kann natürlich mit Zahlen das weiß jeder
mit Statistiken außerordentlich gut
zaubern man muss nicht gleich betrügen
man muss nicht gleich lügen nicht man
kann eleganter zaubern mit Zahlen und
das dahinter hinter dieser scheinbar
wissenschaftlichen Arbeit dann massiver
politischer und wirtschaftlicher Druck
steht das ist eigentlich nicht so
überraschend denn es gilt für viele
andere Bereiche auch ich will kein neues
Fass aufmachen aber ich vermute doch
beim Thema Klimawandel könnte man sehr
ähnliche Beobachtungen
er fand das da auch Profit eine Rolle
gespielt hat haben sie im Zuge ihrer
Recherchen ja Tendenzen gesehen die
diese Gedanken bestätigen oder kann man
auch gelten lassen es ging um Zeit
meinen Namen anders ist die Rettung für
alle und deswegen deswegen machen wir
das jetzt mal ganz schnell wir bewerten
Sie das es war sicherlich beides es ging
um Zeit es musste alles sehr sehr
schnell gehen das ganze der ganze
Zulassungsprozess war mit heißer Nadel
gestrickt
wenn man dann natürlich aber sieht das
Pfizer
2021 ich weiß nicht vielleicht
korrigieren Sie mich glaube 30 oder 35
Milliarden Gewinn gemacht hat
auch
bestimmt nicht nicht schlechter da stand
dann sieht man natürlich dass das ganze
ein extrem
finanziell gesteuertes extrem finanziell
gesteuerter Prozess war ich möchte das
aber auch nicht verurteilen es ist für
mich völlig korrekt wenn Unternehmen
Geld verdienen und wenn sie Geld
verdienen wollen und das das dürfen Sie
auch dass das sollte auch in keinster
Weise irgendwie
unterbunden oder kritisiert werden nur
wenn es so viel um so viel Geld geht
dann muss dann hat die Politik dann
haben die Behörden die Aufgabe das Ganze
zu steuern und zu kontrollieren man
hätte Pfizer hat das war schon oft Thema
die impfstoffverträge die Faser mit den
unterschiedlichen Ländern gemacht hat in
Argentinien dass es das ist jetzt
herausgekommen hat Pfizer ein
Haftungsausschluss gefordert selbst für
Fälle in denen ist selber böswillig
Mängel verschuldet
das finde ich dass sowas gegen sowas
sollte man vorgehen und auch mehr
Transparenz schaffen
und Bürger würden Sie sich wenn Sie
jetzt hier am Tisch sitzen und auch die
Recherchen von Frau boderas hören wenn
Sie sich jetzt heute noch impfen lassen
oder würden sich da Zweifel bei Ihnen
melden das ist eine schwierige Frage ich
lasse auch offen ob ich mich überhaupt
habe impfen lassen das ist eine private
Entscheidung die meinen Körper mich und
vielleicht mein Umfeld noch was angeht
ich finde es ganz wichtig dass sie eben
gesagt haben man sollte sich da jetzt
auch nicht in anti-amerikanische oder
die kapitalistische beißtreflexe
hineintreiben lassen ich finde es gut
dass es forschende Pharmaunternehmen
gibt ich finde es gut dass wir einen
Markt haben auf dem wir verschiedene
Produkte haben ich finde es gut dass es
Innovationen gibt ich finde es gut dass
Menschen vorangehen etwas erfinden es
gab ja wirklich die Pandemie ist ja
nicht komplett die sich erfunden worden
ist ja ganz klar sagen es sind viele
Leute auch daran gestorben an Corona
dadurch das infiziert waren nur eben die
Politik hat die bringt Schuld die
verschiedenen
ersten Player sozusagen
auszuballancieren und zwei Dinge Stellen
mich eben kolossal sie haben vorhin
gesagt mit dem Wissen von heute ja das
ist heute anders ja da muss aufgeklärt
werden aber zwei Sachen ging eben schon
damals nicht dass Herr Lauterbach der
auf irgendwelchen wegen die wir so genau
nicht kennen ein Professoren Titel
bekommen hat der auch ein Mediziner ist
dass er sich ein hinstellt und sagt ist
ein nebenwirkungsfreier Impfung also
mein Hausarzt sagt mir schon immer
selbst wenn du dich gegen Grippe impfen
lässt oder dir sonst eine Spritze geben
lässt ganz nebenwirkungsfrei kann ich
Dir nicht garantieren ich empfehle es
dir aber du musst es entscheiden das ist
der sogenannte mündige aufgeklärte
Patient das ist das eine was ich
kritisiere also diese Rede von der
nebenwirkungsfreien Impfung und das
zweite z.B das Teil zum Beispiel ist
eben das mit einer brachialen Lust an
der Ausgrenzung gegen jene vorgegangen
ist dies anders gesehen haben ich fand
damals völlig in Ordnung wenn man sagt
leute lasst euch impfen es ist
freiwillig es sind Angebot da geht er
hin es kostet nichts macht es schnell
nutzt euch was aber genauso muss es auch
möglich sein zu sagen ich mag nicht und
statt aber dann bestraft zu werden dass
man nicht ist Krankenhaus durfte seine
Sterbenden Eltern vielleicht nicht
besuchen durfte in den Kindergarten
seine Kinder nicht abbringen durfte
nicht in Bibliotheken durfte wo sonst
immer heißt Bibliothek ist Kultur für
alle auf einmal war dann zwei g plus
also du darfst natürlich lesen wenn du
frisch geimpft bist oder sonst einen
Bescheinigung hast da haben wir glaube
ich Raubbau mindestens genauso stark an
unserer Gesellschaft unserer Demokratie
betrieben wie vielleicht in unserer
nationalen Gesundheit wurden sie
abgezockt oder reingelegt das ist also
eine Verzehnfachung das kann nicht wahr
sein jetzt melden unsere Reporter
kümmern sich um Ihren Fall vielen Dank